chemical weapon is defined in the
Commission and there are different
substances which are considered as
chemical weapon but in general it is
also added that any chemical substance
which could be used you know against
human beings or environment against
nature and which could be harmful to
human beings should be considered as
chemical weapons so this is a very
general definition which I welcome that
I think it gives also i clear signal to
individuals as well as countries that
they should not misuse the chemistry
that's they should not misuse anything
which might be used for peaceful
purposes but at the same time which
could be harmful to the people so this
is strictly prohibited by the convention
so they actually they have to abide by
their obligations